whether women started with a simple
premise which is that we live in
relationship with one another and that
we're essentially relational responsive
people so the idea of a sort of isolated
individual standing alone looking up at
the sky for sort of eternal principles
whether they were content principles or
whatever you know was it was like no no
look look around you you know you live
it's like you live we live on a
trampoline and if we take if we move it
affects a whole lot of people so you
have to be very aware of those
relationships so it was not as if women
were taking the opposite they were
questioning the whole paradigm not
explicitly but implicitly I remember I
was teaching a section of this class
where they were talking about moral
dilemmas you know if you were in a
lifeboat did you jump out you know that
kind of thing
so anyway then there was the Vietnam War
was going on and college students were
being drafted and in my section I we
tried to talk about the war and the
students didn't want to talk about it
and I thought that was very interesting
particularly the men and the reason was
I realized is that their decisions about
the war were based not only on you know
timeless principles of just an unjust
war but how their actions would affect
people who they loved and care about
their family you know maybe a love
relationship or something
and they knew that to care about
relationships was to be like a woman so
they didn't want to say it but they also
had enough integrity that they didn't
want to misrepresent themselves so I
remember as a teaching a move I we read
cow Moos novel the plague which is if
you suddenly find yourself in the middle
of a city you know and the plague comes
even though you didn't you weren't
responsible what was your responsibility
to other people and so forth and I
remember it was great because we're in
this long discussion of this novel the
plague and one of the students said
that's the draft dilemma and then we
really started talking about so I knew
that this these theories that Reb
scented men as thinking only in the
abstract if they were morally mature and
so forth were not reflecting men's life
either but it was after that time of
hearing women's voices and I have to
emphasize that because in that study we
interviewed at Street clinics in the
south end of Boston and it you know in
University Health Services we had the
most we had a very diverse range of
women's voices both in terms of
ethnicity and social class and it was
listening to other women that focused
for me what was the problem in these
theories that weren't representing women
or men accurately and that's why my book
was called not in a woman's voice but it
was called in a different voice and
here's a different voice in a different
way of listening to men and women and to
ourselves instead of whose rights took
precedence the question was what is the
responsible thing to do when you find
yourself in a situation of relationship
where there seems to be no way of acting
that will not cause hurt so for example
one woman was a nurse and she was
married to a roofer who was out of work
and she had scoliosis of the spine and
she had one child who was one years old
and she was Catholic
so her doctor told her if she continued
the pregnancy she would have injured her
spine and she would be unable to work or
care for her child so what does she do
you know it's not like whose rights take
precedence what does she do in
relationship to herself her Catholicism
the existing child the unemployed roof
her husband her spine it and so instead
of this sort of what's the absolute
right thing to do it's like you know
what is the better thing to do in a
situation there's no good thing to do
and you know it was interesting because
one of the things that was so amazing to
me as I listen to women there was this
understanding particularly then but I
think still now that the good woman is
selfless that the good
and you know is responsive to everybody
else's needs so I would hear women tell
me that you wouldn't even matter what
like that they were going to they wanted
to have the child because their
boyfriend wanted them to or they wanted
to have the abortion because their
parents wanted them to finish school or
something like that and I would say you
know and they would say I want to be
responsive to them and I would say
that's great but what do you want they
would look at me and they would say
what's wrong with being responsive to
other people's needs or to people's
needs so I would say nothing I said but
you're a person what about your needs
and why is it good to be responsive to
other people and selfish to respond to
yourself because that's the word they
would use whatever they wanted who was
to have the abortion continue the
pregnancy that was selfish and and they
would look at me this was in 1973 4 5
and they would say good question and it
was that this whole ethic of
selflessness was morally problematic as
it was an abdication of voice and
relationship and responsibility but if
women came into these relationships then
it was going to be a different
conversation that's what that book was
about so you know I hadn't seen it and
it was a moment of you know what would
you call it like Epiphany and I remember
sitting down on my kitchen table and
writing this paper called in a different
voice just to make sense of my situation
and then it was amazing for me to
discover that so many women felt the
same way that we were not supposed to
say what we knew from experience
you